En una tienda tienen 4 marcas de pesticidas.
Cada una tiene diferentes concentraciones
y también tiene diferente tamaño de botella.
Tenemos estas 4 marcas, A, B, C, D, tenemos
el tamaño de las botellas en mililitros
o en litros, tenemos la concentración, que
es el porcentaje del volumen de fluido
que corresponde al pesticida y el precio por botella.
Si se quiere tener más ingrediente activo
por lo que se paga,
se debe comprar la botella de la marca...
Aquí tenemos que elegir.
Los invito a que pausen el video y piensen en ello.
Tenemos que pensar en la cantidad de
el ingrediente activo...
ingrediente activo por botella en ml...
En este primer caso tenemos 375 ml de la botella
y el 65% de concentración,
el 65% de 375 nos da...
375 por 0.65 igual a 243.75...
son 243.75 ml...
mililitros por botella...
Es importante que conservemos las unidades...
por botella...
¿Cuál será el ingrediente activo por dólar?
Ingrediente activo por dólar...
Bueno, pues tenemos esta cantidad, la vamos
a dividir entre el precio, es 243.75 entre 22.
Usamos lo que tenemos en la calculadora y
esto lo dividimos entre 22, nos da... 11.07...
11.07 ml por dólar.
Otra forma de pensar en ello, es que si tengo
243.75 ml por botella y quiero llegar a algo
que tenga ml por dólar, pues a esto lo voy
a tener que multiplicar por algo que tenga...
bueno quiero deshacerme de las botellas, aquí
en el denominador, así que va a ser algo
que tenga botella en el numerador y tenga
dólar en el denominador.
Así con el análisis dimensional, yo puedo
quitar estas unidades de botella y me queda
en mililitros por dólar, que es lo que busco.
¿Y cuántas botellas hay en un dólar?
Bueno, suena medio extraña la pregunta.
Otra forma de pensar en ello es que una botella
cuesta 22 dólares,
así que multipliquemos 243.75 por 1 entre 22 ó dividimos 243.75 entre 22 y nos da esta cantidad de...
que lo voy a recorrer para tener espacio para
escribir la cantidad numérica...
y quedamos que son 11.07 ml por dólar, ya
que aquí cancelamos las botellas
y nos quedan las unidades de ml por dólar, aquí.
Podemos aplicar el sentido común, esto es
lo que tenemos en una botella que cuesta 22 dólares,
por lo que dividimos esto entre
22 y así obtenemos los ml por dólar.
Vamos a hacer esto para todas las
demás opciones de marcas.
Ésta es del primero...
el siguiente es, 750 ml y la concentración
es del 35%, multiplicamos 750 por 35% igual
a 262.5 ml por botella
y esto lo dividimos entre el costo que es 21... entre 21...
y nos da 12.5 ml por dólar...
ml por dólar...
La siguiente tenemos aquí 1 litro, no mililitros,
pero sabemos que 1 litro es igual a 1000 mililitros
y el 75% de mil va a ser igual a 750 ml por botella
y estos 750 lo dividimos entre el costo
de 68 dólares, de 68 dólares.
750 entre 68 =11.029, redondemos a 11.03 ml por dólar.
Finalmente tenemos la marca D que son 1.5
litros o lo que es lo mismo 1500 ml,
1 litro es igual a 1000 mililitros, 1 litro y medio va a ser igual a 1000 más 500, 1500 mililitros al 30%.
El 30% de 1500 mililitros son 450 ml...
450 ml por botella...
y si eso lo dividimos entre 40,
450 entre 40, nos da 11.25...
nos da 11.25 ml por dólar.
¿Cuál es la mejor opción?
Pues es la que tenga más mililitros por dólar,
vemos de estas 4 opciones,
es nuestra opción B o la marca B.
Nuestra respuesta es la opción B.